MALE SPEAKER: Today we are
joined by two inspirational
storytellers from Oracle
Team USA--
Julian Guthrie.
She's the author of "The
Billionaire and the Mechanic."
And we're also joined by
Joseph Ozanne who is an
engineer with Oracle Team USA.
Please join me in welcoming
them to Google.
Thank you very much.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: So my book,
"The Billionaire and the
Mechanic: How Larry Ellison and
a Car Mechanic Teamed Up
to Win Sailing's Greatest Race,
The America's Cup," it's
been out for about a month.
It's official pub
date was June 4.
And we've had a great
reception.
Happily it landed.
It's a national best-seller.
And this last weekend I noticed
it was number nine on
the northern California
best seller list.
And we also have an option
on it for a film.
So I hope you like the book
because at some point you may
see it as a feature film.
And I'll be taking suggestions
later for
who should play Larry.
And that will be interesting
coming from here.
And who will play the mechanic,
whose name is
Norbert Bajurin.
And he's a great part
of this story.
He is the commodore of the
Golden Gate Yacht Club today.
And he was in 2001 when
this all was launched.
So this is a story really about
these two men who seem
so different, the billionaire
and the mechanic.
And their singular quest for
the America's Cup, which is
the oldest trophy in
international sports.
And I started this story
because I was really
interested in the drama of
going after the Cup.
But again, this unusual
partnership
between Larry and Norbert.
And Norbert, as I said, was the
commodore of the Golden
Gate Yacht Club-- which
this was in 2001.
The yacht club, for those of you
who may know it, it's down
beyond past the better
known, more elite St.
Francis Yacht Club.
When I went there when Norbert
became commodore, it was
basically a sinking ship.
It was $450,000 in debt.
And he feared he had been named
the commodore who would
close the doors and
lower the burgee.
So he was reaching out, grasping
at straws, trying to
find a way to save this old
blue-collar boating
institution on the San Francisco
waterfront when he
read, lo and behold, that
Larry Ellison and Oracle
Racing had had a falling out
with the St. Francis.
And he thought, well, why can't
our little club be the
sponsoring club of
Oracle Racing?
And everybody around him
said, you're nuts.
This is never going to happen.
Why would Oracle Racing and
Larry Ellison partner with
this kind of unknown club
sinking in debt.
Well, he didn't listen
to the naysayers.
And he made the deal happen.
Along the way in about three
months, I think he
lost about 30 pounds.
And he was working at the
radiator shop by day, and he
was negotiating this
deal at night.
And he was trying to save the
Golden Gate Yacht Club and
make it into the little
engine that could.
So they formed this unlikely
friendship and partnership
that exists today.
And so this story is about
the two of them.
But it's also about many of the
builders, and the sailors,
and the engineers who dreamed
for much of their lives of
being a part of a winning
America's Cup team.
Whether it's a Jimmy Spithill,
the sailor of Oracle Racing,
who dreamed from when he was
a child of being a part of
winning the America's
Cup on the sailboat.
He's an Australian.
And he was four years old, I
believe, when Australia rested
the Cup away from America in
1983 after the longest winning
streak in sports.
And parties rang out on
his beach for weeks.
And he thought, I'm going
to be a part of this
someday, and he was.
Or whether it's Joseph
Ozanne who wanted--
from the time he was a child--
to be a part of this thing
called the America's Cup, but
not to be on the boat, but to
be someone who designed,
who engineer the boats.
And so my book tells the story
of the dreams, the human
drama, the unlikely
partnerships, the losses that
led to the ultimate
victory in 2010.
So I'm going to read just a
couple of very quick vignettes
from the book.
And this book starts in the
Sydney to Hobart Race of 1998,
which I'm sure most of
you have heard about.
It was, at the time, the worst
maritime disaster in
Australian history.
Larry Ellison, who is an
accomplished sailor, he was
racing on his boat, "Sayonara."
And they had just
come through the eye
of the hurricane,
which was not predicted.
So they were all taken by
surprise and felt that their
lives were definitely
in danger.
So this is when they've
come out of
the eye of the hurricane.
And this is an important place
to start the book and just
start this story because, for
one thing, after Larry Ellison
completed this race, he said
no more open ocean racing.
I'm done with this.
I'm going for around
the buoys regattas.
But it also, for him, reminded
him of the impermanence of all
things, of the fragile state
of life as we know it.
And that is something that has
stayed with him today.
And this race remains very
significant in his life.
And I'm reading this part that
as a writer I'm very proud of
because I think that it's
very evocative.
And I love the language of it.
So thanks for humoring
me a little bit.
"On the morning of the third
day, the sun was just coming
up as 'Sayonara' entered the
Derwent River, an estuary
leading to the capital
of Tasmania.
A salmon pink light cut through
the mauve morning sky.
The crew of 'Sayonara,' the
first to reach the Derwent,
was welcomed by a small
powerboat with a man on board
playing Scottish highland
bagpipes, the traditional
welcome for a winning boat.
On this day, the songs
were somber.
The wind was a whisper,
blowing at
less than eight knots.
Larry and his crew were in the
river valley, and the wild
flowers, fern, and towering
trees carpeted deep-cut
canyons with red dirt ridges.
The wild flowers in shades of
blue, white, crimson, purple,
and heather were bathed
in soft pink light.
Larry closed his eyes for a
moment listening to the sounds
of the bagpipe and to the waves
gently lapping at the
side of the boat.
The air was perfectly calm.
The waves like a reassuring
heartbeat.
The glory of life was theirs."
So that was, as I said,
that was a very
significant turning point--
surviving the Sydney to Hobart
and coming out of that.
So I'm going to jump around
a little bit.
And the next scene I'm
going to read just
a little bit from.
I'm going to cut my talk a
little bit short because I
want to get to Joseph.
Because his story is
really fantastic.
And you're going to see
some great video--
it's going to astound you--
of the new boats and of the boat
that won the America's
Cup for Oracle Racing in 2010.
So I'm going to read
something.
When I was interviewing Larry
Ellison, we got to talking
about his friendship with Steve
Jobs and about the time
that the two of them
spent together.
And he gave me a lot of great
detail on their friendship and
their talks.
And here is one where
they are walking
the grounds of Larry's--
then under construction--
Woodside estate and talking
about who was the greatest
person ever.
Yeah.
So you can make your own guesses
as to who you think
they will each choose.
It's kind of an interesting
Rorschach test.
So here's Larry talking.
"I'm talking about greatness,
about taking a lever to the
world and moving it, Larry said
walking the grounds of
his new Woodside property with
his best friend, Steve Jobs.
I'm not talking about
moral perfection.
I'm talking about people who
changed the world the most
during their lifetime.
Jobs, who had returned to Apple
three years earlier,
enjoyed the conversational
volleying and placed Leonardo
da Vinci and Gandhi as
his top choices, with
Gandhi in the lead.
Leonardo, a great artist and an
inventor lived in violent
times and was a designer of
tanks, battlements, ramparts,
and an assortment of other
military tools, and castle
fortifications.
Larry joked that had Leonardo
not been gay, he would have
been quote unquote, 'a perfect
fit for the Bush
administration.' Jobs who had
studied in India cited
Gandhi's doctrine of nonviolent
revolution as an
example of how it was possible
to remain morally pure while
aggressively pursuing change.
Larry's choice for history's
greatest person could not have
been more different
from Gandhi.
His choice was the Corsican-born
military leader,
Napoleon Bonaparte."
Here's Larry talking.
'Napoleon overthrew kings and
tyrants throughout Europe,
created a system of free public
schools, and wrote one
set of laws that apply
to everybody.
Napoleon achieved liberal ends
through conservative means,'
Larry argued.
Steve and Larry argued
about everything,
including music and art.
When Larry said he thought Paul
Simon's lyrics for 'The
Boxer' were brilliant, Steve
laughed and said Larry didn't
know goodness from greatness.
Dylan, Job's said, is the
genius of our time.
It never stopped.
No one gave in, and they both
enjoy the rallying.
Before Larry and Steve parted
ways, Larry mentioned recent
regattas he had won on
'Sayonara.' And he talked
about the America's Cup race
he was readying for.
Steve was interested in
materials and the innovations,
whether the Mylar used on the
sails, or the grade of carbon
fiber in the hulls.
Part of Larry's job, as he saw
it, was to tempt and corrupt
his friend with boats and planes
so that he would have
more fun and more time.
Steve was always concerned about
conspicuous consumption.
He likes cars and motorcycles
but never spent a lot money.
What he loved was designing and
redesigning things to make
them more useful and
more beautiful."
I think this is a neat
little anecdote here.
"Larry was on the Apple Board
in 2000 when he had the idea
that Apple should give Steve a
$40 million Gulfstream jet, so
he could more efficiently
take his family to
Hawaii for long weekends.
Immediately, Steve started
designing the interior of his
new plane, studying Larry's
Gulfstream and making
improvements on Larry's
design.
When he noticed that Larry had
one button to open a door and
another button to close it--"
Can you imagine?
"Steve decided on a single
toggle switch that would do
both on his plane.
Steve reversed the placement of
the sink and shower in the
bathroom on his plane
among other changes.
Larry agreed that Steve's
redesigns were improvements.
Larry, sure he would eventually
hook his best
friend on the draw the sea, also
lent Steve his boat for
family vacations.
Steve returned home after 10
days aboard 'Katana' and
enthused, no one bothers
you on the boat.
You can read and think and watch
the sky change colors at
the end of the day.
Soon Steve was showing Larry
designs for his beautiful boat
to be named 'Aqua.'
Well, the boat didn't end up
being named 'Aqua.' It's
called 'Venus.' And it's my
belief it was recently
completed, and that Lorraine
and their family
is enjoying it now.
But that was one thing that
Larry was able to, quote
unquote, 'corrupt' his
best friend about."
So now we're going to
move quickly back to
the America's Cup.
And I included the Steve Jobs,
Larry Ellison scene.
And there's also a scene at
Steve's memorial service,
which has never been
reported before.
Because the book is very
much about dreamers.
And it's about finding
innovations in whatever you
do, which Joseph is going
to talk about.
So this is a very, very small
vignette that I'm going to
read about "America," the
first boat that won the
America's Cup for the United
States in 1851.
And it's going to be a great
contrast to the boat that
Joseph is going to talk about.
And then I'm going to read one
little final vignette about--
How are we doing on time?
So this boat was built in 1840s
for around $20,000.
And the boat that won the
America's Cup that raced
basically for two races was
a $40 million boat.
So there have been a
few advancements in
that regard, as well.
So this is a little vignette
about "America."
"'America,' offered up as United
States' finest display
of innovation on the water was
a 95-foot, black, gaff-rigged
schooner with a concave bow,
low free board, and cotton
sails, said to hold their shape
better than the flax
sails of the British yachts and
shaped on the lines of a
pilot boat.
She had set sail from New York's
East River in June and
was manned throughout her
Atlantic crossing by Captain
WH Brown and a crew of 12 men.
Brown had built 'America'
for $20,000 in cash.
The Marquis of Anglesey, a
member of the Royal Yacht
Squadron formed in 1815, and
the first club in England
granted the royal designation,
took one look at 'America' and
said, if she is right,
we are all wrong.
And another Brit remarked that
'America' looked like a, quote
unquote, 'hawk among
pigeons.'"
So now we're going to move
to the final little
vignette that have.
And if "America" was a "hawk
among pigeons," then we'll
have to come up with good
descriptives for this "USA
17." Larry called it his
black pterodactyl.
And, you know, it would
certainly be up there with a
peregrine falcon, going
back to the birds.
So this is where Joseph's
story really comes
in into this book.
Although, he had been
engineering and designing
boats for years before.
But so this when Oracle Racing
has lost twice, 2003, 2007.
Larry's been called a chump,
been likened to a modern day
Sir Thomas Lipton.
And he came back with what
he thought would
be a winning formula.
And that was, hire Russell
Coutts, the winningest skipper
in America's Cup history.
And build a boat, the
likes of which had
never been seen before.
So this is a pretty exciting
part of the story.
"One month after the issue of
the venue was decided, 50 men
and two enormous cranes came
together on the San Diego
docks to hoist a brand new rigid
wing, made of carbon
fiber and Kevlar and wrapped
in white aeronautical film
onto 'USA 17.'
The wing had grown from 150 feet
to 196 feet, to 206 feet,
and finally to an astounding
230 feet.
At 23 stories, it was too
tall to fit under
the Golden Gate Bridge.
The wing was approximately the
same area as a football field,
but as fragile as an egg.
To better understand the power
of the rigid wing, Jimmy
Spithill had spent two
weeks taking an
intensive course in flying.
He figured the best way to learn
to sail this aerodynamic
wonder was to get his
pilot's license.
So on a rare break, he returned
home to Australia,
visited a small country
airfield, and explained to the
guys what he wanted to do.
His flight instructor, also a
sailor, took him out every day
for hours at a time in weather
that grounded other planes.
Jimmy was immediately struck
by the similarities between
flying and sailing.
A well set-up plane, one driven
smoothly was easy to
fly and had less drag.
In the same way, a properly
balanced boat, trimmed well,
was easy to sail.
The experience hooked
him on flying.
When Jimmy stepped aboard 'USA
17,' which they called 'The
Beast,' he briefly looked up.
It was as if someone had ripped
the wing off of a jet
liner and placed
it on his boat.
The plan for the day had been to
go out and take it slow and
easy so the crew could gradually
began to get a feel
for the huge winged sailboat.
But the boat wanted to fly.
And once Dirk de Ridder started
to trust the data,
Jimmy felt like a jockey trying
to hold back his horse.
He asked Scott Ferguson, a
designer on board, whether he
could fly a hull and accelerate
'USA 17' to a much
higher speed.
'Now is a good a time
as any,' Ferguson
said, holding his breath.
As the boat outperformed
anyone's expectations,
Ferguson had tears
in his eyes.
Joseph Ozanne and Mike Drummond
watched in awe as
their experimental side project
became the main event.
Larry had been told to get to
San Diego as soon as possible
so he could see the wing sail.
As he approached Lindbergh
Field, near the San Diego
Harbor, he banked his CJ4
twin-jet over the harbor and
looked down.
That's when he saw the winged
trimaran for the first time.
Seeing the boat from the air,
he thought to himself, oh my
god, what have we done.
This is madness.
When 'USA 17' returned to the
docks, the entire team of
engineers, builders, and
sailors were there.
They still had a regatta to win
in Valencia, but they had
already pulled off one of the
biggest engineering victories
in maritime history."
So Joseph is a very
interesting guy.
And you're going to love seeing
the video, and hearing
him talk, and asking
us questions after.
But he was 29 when he joined
Oracle Racine in 2004.
And he was told, after the
2007 loss, to go off and
investigate this rigid wing and
see if this can be done.
And mostly it was this--
what you call "the
Utopian idea," right?
That it was kind
of fantastical.
And he had graduated from a very
prestigious university,
Supra Aero, in France, which
was dedicated to aerospace.
And there's a funny
story about--
when I was talking with him that
he told me about how his
professors used to rib him
about, why are you at an
aerospace school when
you're interested in
studying boat design.
And so why was that?
What was it for you that was
so interesting about boats?
JOSEPH OZANNE: First because
there is no other option.
Because finding a good school
for learning boat
design is not easy.
And also because now,
I mean, a boat is
such a complex machine.
But it's the same physics
behind that.
And you've got wings on the
sail boat, except that the
wings, instead of being
horizontal, are being vertical.
And now we've got even it's
aerodynamic, hydrodynamics.
So it's the same concept
behind that.
So it's a great way to learn.
I mean, aircraft have been
designed for years and years.
And they are just very
nice machines now.
And as a boat designer you try
to use what's done on this
field and to apply all the
techniques of aeronautics in
the boat design.
It's just like amazing because
we can do great things.
And we have now, the machine
you're going to see on the
video are just amazing.
And it's just like a
little aircraft.
So it literally flies
above the water.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: So the wing sail
that reached 230 feet,
the largest wing ever
built for air
or for sea was largely--
there were other people
working on it.
But Joseph, again, took it from
this Utopian vision to a
reality that that boat, the
likes of which will not be
seen again.
But so now, how does what you
learned there apply to what
we're going to see?
Because we're going to
see this video clip.
A little bit, you'll see
the end of 2010.
You'll see "USA 17," the
trimaran, and then you'll see
these new boats.
JOSEPH OZANNE: Yeah, so
basically when we design a
boat that means the way we
work and when we race,
especially America's Cup, the
only thing that matters for
us, is being fast
on the water.
So whatever we do,
we just do it for
being faster and faster.
So the speed is really
the only criteria
we're looking at.
And at the end, so
when we saw--
when we designed "USA
17," there was
no rigid wing, initially.
And we just looked for
a solution to go even
faster on the water.
And the rigid wing was a
solution that was maybe was
kind of obvious.
But it was just such
a project.
And sure to scale it, it was a
bit of an unknown in terms of,
was it feasible, was
it manageable.
And at the end of the day,
I mean, we design
and build this wing.
And it's like it
was a success.
I mean, thanks to that,
the America's Cup is--
we won the America's Cup and the
America's Cup is here in
San Francisco now.
So it's just like a nice
story for that.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: It
is a nice story.
But also an interesting story
because it brings together
part of the various parts of
an America's Cup team, the
engineers, the builders,
and the sailors.
And Joseph and his peers had
to work with the sailors to
kind of help them understand
this new way of sailing that
was very data driven.
And can you talk a little
bit about that?
JOSEPH OZANNE: What's
fascinating is so we have
obviously some sailing
team which is an
amazing sailing team.
So we work with the best
sailors in the world.
And it's just as an amateur
sailor, it's always very
impressive to work
with these guys.
You're all new.
I mean, it's just like
you work with the
best guy in this sport.
So initially, I mean, we are
seen like engineers.
So we are computer guys.
On the paper we constantly
interact with them.
So we spent a lot of time
talking to them and exchanging
ideas and discussion about
what's happening on the water,
what's happening on
the computer.
Now what's really interesting
is so they kind of liked the
idea of having a wing, but
obviously they had no
idea how to use it.
So first, our job is to model
the wing and model the boat.
So we know how to trim it,
what's the best settings.
And it's kind of weird
for them to have
new tools like that.
And so you have to tell
them how to use it.
So you ended up in a situation
where you give advice, how to
sail a boat, to the best guy
in the world, you know.
So they've been doing his
job for years and years.
And you ended up like, you know,
you should trim your
boat or your wing that way.
And said, your initial reaction
could've been, why
are you telling me that.
But then little by little you
build kind of a relationship
and a trust between the sailors
and the designers.
And you end up doing
great things.
So again, it's really
an interaction with
two different worlds.
And that's great, but the
America's Cup is this
technology being this bridge
between the two worlds.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: Do you
want to show the--
JOSEPH OZANNE: Yeah, I see we
could, I guess we'd have an
idea of what we're
talking about.
So obviously
"} rigid wing is about the
farthest technology now.
And it is a pretty well-known
technology.
And we make a lot of
progress in that.
And also now, the boats are
flying above the water.
So you saw in the video
that you don't have
any more hull immersed.
So it's really a brand
new world,
brand new era for sailing.
And it's where for us, as a
designer, it's just like a
super exciting challenge.
And because we're bringing
sailing in a new dimension.
So we need to work with this
sort of dimension.
Now we can lift the boat
above the water.
And we have problems
to solve exactly
like in flight mechanics.
So we need to work on stability
to be able to
maintain the flight.
And how we can drive
these things.
And so it's really, really
the focus is--
I mean, we didn't want to,
we didn't look for
flying at any price.
You know, just went
there because it
was the fastest solution.
So we just like--
our approach, we just try
to design the boat.
And we look for solutions.
And you ended up with this
kind of machine.
And I think this machine is
really a sailing machine.
We can go two or three
times the wind speed.
So whatever is the wind, we can
double or triple of the
speed of the wind just
without any engine.
So it's just like you ended up
with an incredible piece of
technology.
And this is, I think, the
fascinating part of our job is
to be able to understand
how this very
complex system works.
So it's really a machine that
works in between two--
I mean, you've got the air
and you've got the water.
And so, I think, in my mind, it
is a bit more complex than
even an aircraft, because
aircraft you
only have air around.
And it's just like always
symmetrical.
In other words, staying
in the same direction.
Where on the sailboat you need
to have the interaction
between what's happening in the
air and what's happening
in the water.
And whatever you do, one part
is affecting the other one.
So it's like whatever rudder
angle you give, or whatever
change of direction you have,
it's going to affect the flow
above as well.
It's going to affect
the engine.
So at the end--
I mean, what [INAUDIBLE]
engine is going
to affect the wing.
So at the end, it's really a
complex equation to sort.
And what's fascinating, and I
thing it was also fascinating
to work with the sailors
for that purpose.
Because we give them a machine,
but they have to
understand how to use it.
So it's really understanding
this equation.
It's very complex and
very exciting.
Because then, when you see this
kind of picture, and this
kind of speed, I think
it's quite a success.
And it's quite a good thing
for the sport, as well.
So--
JULIAN GUTHRIE: Well, now you
have a wing in the air, and
then you have the wiglets
underneath.
So you've got these wings above
and wings below that
you're designing which
is very cool looking.
JOSEPH OZANNE: That's why you
can learn from aircrafts
because basically, we have
a wing, vertical
to propel the boat.
And now we reach some speeds
that we can lift the boat,
exactly like a normal wing.
You lift the boat
in the water.
So we've got hydrofoils.
And the boat roughly--
the one you saw--
are roughly seven tons.
The platform, plus the
wing, plus the crew.
So you can lift, really, your
boat with a speed we are
reaching, you can really lift
the boat above the water.
So you ended up creating a seven
ton force to lift the
weight of the boat from this
little horizontal wing that
are below the water.
So with maybe one or two square
meters of carbon, you
can just literally fly
above the water.
And you ended up reaching speeds
of 40, 45 knots, which
is roughly 50 miles an hour.
So it's really, I mean,
especially in San Francisco
when you ride, I mean,
you sail along
the Golden Gate Bridge.
I think the limit on the
Golden Gate Bridge
is 45 miles an hour.
So you just go faster
than the cars.
So it's just like--
So it's quite interesting,
and it's quite
fascinating for the purpose.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: So is this
better than you imagined?
Or is it like when you were
thinking about, I could be a
part of this design team or
engineering team, or how far
the design in the
sport has gone?
I mean--
JOSEPH OZANNE: I think
the sky is the limit.
Normally, you can go,
I mean, we can--
JULIAN GUTHRIE: The
sky is the limit.
JOSEPH OZANNE: Yeah, the thing
is, basically you try always.
I mean, we do everything
we can to go faster.
And what's interesting here is
inside the America's Cup you
still have a rule to follow.
So we've got to search
the pages, document
that gives the rules.
So everybody has, more or
less, the same boat.
So as an engineer, it's very
interesting because you need
to be the fastest possible
inside this rule.
But so this is why we didn't
start it from scratch.
So we just have a basic
set of rules.
And our work is to go
as fast as possible.
Again, that's pretty basic.
But the only thing we try to
do is just to go faster.
So that's why we are really
at the beginning of
a new era in sailing.
So I'm pretty sure
we can improve.
And I'm pretty sure we can
have even better design.
But the technology and the,
I mean, this summer
is going to be great.
Because we're going to have
several teams that work
individually on these designs.
So we can have competition.
You saw, we have
two boats here.
So we have already some internal
competition just to
get up to speed.
But every day we go sailing, and
we just learn new stuff.
And it's a new dimension
for that.
So I think it's great
for the sport.
It's going to be awesome.
In September, we're going
to see what's happening.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: Oh, we'll see.
We'll see how your designs
do, right?
JOSEPH OZANNE: Exactly.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: So I know we
wanted to have some time to
open it up for questions.
So who has questions
for either of us?
AUDIENCE: The original
class rules
didn't anticipate foiling.
And obviously, the kiwis
figured that out.
And now everyone's followed.
Could you elaborate a
little bit on how--
is that just because you're able
to get more lift than was
anticipated?
Or can you talk a little
about how the
transition to foiling happened?
JOSEPH OZANNE: I think it's a
natural development in a sense
that again, what we try to
do is to reduce drag.
So basically, our main
job is to reduce the
drag as much as possible.
And what's happening is
one big source of
drag is the hull itself.
So traditionally, foiling is not
new in the sailing world.
And there have been
foilers before.
So it's a natural thing to
try to lift the boat.
And initially in the rule, the
people that wrote the rule
said try to avoid that because
it's kind of a bit dangerous
and it's a bit tricky to manage,
but to try to that.
But I mean, if you got the
way to do that anyway.
And so the Kiwi were the first
one to really speak true of
the foiling.
We've been sailing on our
smaller catamarans and we've
been foiling as well.
So it's just like, we did a
lot of experiments on the
45-footer, which is the smallest
kind of this boat.
And so it's just a natural
development.
Because you try to reduce drag,
you end up foiling.
And you figure out a solution
to be able to foil and fly
inside the rule.
So it's kind of whenever
we do fast materials,
you end up in this--
I'm pretty sure, we can end up
in this kind of situation.
And I'm pretty sure we're going
to see more and more
boats like that.
Because it's just like,
it's faster.
So.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned the
constraints that are
introduced by the rules
of the race.
And also I mean, I'm not a big
expert on the America's Cup,
but I'm noticing
a lot of people
running around the boat.
Obviously, you know sailing is a
team sport, and all of that.
But let's say that you had
absolute freedom to remove all
of those constraints.
And are there chances that
that will change?
The constraints will change over
time, based on the new
designs and so on.
And the second one, are those
people really still needed?
Can you, like, replace
them with--
JULIAN GUTHRIE: Technology?
AUDIENCE: Or is it just because
of the tradition?
JOSEPH OZANNE: So to answer
the first part of the
question, I mean, that's
interesting in America's Cup
is we're still racing.
So we have a race course.
And so we need to go upwind,
we need to go downwind.
So we need to have
a proper race.
So there is a lot
of compromise.
So you can tune a boat for going
upwind, you can tune
your boat for downwind.
And it's very interesting
because you have to trade off
the different operating
conditions.
And depending on what you do,
you could end up with
different design.
For example our two boats, they
are slightly different in
terms of tuning.
So one is better upwind,
one is better downwind.
So we need to figure out which
one is the best solution.
So we don't do a boat
for speed record.
If you have to do a boat
And they can go faster.
The speed record right
now is like 65 knots,
something like that.
But it's a machine that
couldn't-- it's impossible to
sail in the Bay.
So we really have an envelope.
And I see America's Cup
is still a race.
So you're going to have mark
rounding, and you're going to
have a starting line
and finishing line.
And you're going to have to work
upwind and downwind so to
sail inside the rules.
So I don't think this envelope
will disappear.
And the second part of your
question was more about
simulation, right?
AUDIENCE: Like the people
that operate the boat.
JOSEPH OZANNE: Exactly.
So what's interesting here is
for us, I mean, we struggled
to model how to drive a boat.
So if you give to a computer the
power to drive the boat,
it's not that easy to do.
And the guys, they are
just incredible.
They feel the wind, how to
react, anticipate, and
everything.
And we're still at the level
where I don't think we are
really able to capture
the skills of
the sailors for that.
So we still need them
to go fast.
And they are extremely
good for that.
So when we give them
a machine.
They are able to say, OK.
That's what we can
do with that.
We can't.
So that sets the envelope
of performance.
And so you still want people
involved, first
because it's a sport.
So you want people involved.
But also because it's still
the fastest solution.
So what's happening is it's
interesting because in my few
times I met people from Formula
One industry or from
the aeronautic world, and I've
been asking more or less the
same question is, how do you
model the human behavior to
make sure that we
can understand
exactly what's happening.
And in Formula One, you
have a lot of money,
and a lot of people.
And even more in aeronautics
we're going Airbus or Boeing.
Even these guys that still give
simulators to the pilots
just to make sure that they
can collect proper
information, which proves that
you still need somebody to
drive the machine and
to drive it faster.
AUDIENCE: So I get that part.
Like you still get
the skipper.
But like the people that are
just standing around pulling
winches and just basically are
being used as a weight.
Are those tradition?
JOSEPH OZANNE: Yes.
It's probably a tradition in a
sense that the only source of
energy needs to be human.
So we don't have any engine.
So we use hydraulics
under the loads.
But the hydraulic pumps are
driven by the sailors.
AUDIENCE: In other words, can
you reduce the number of
people significantly?
JOSEPH OZANNE: Without human
power, it's going to be hard
to trim the boat.
So you need this because you
need a certain amount of
energy to handle the loads.
So on this boat, there
are 11 on board.
And they would be happy
with more people.
It's such hard work that
you need these guys.
So without any external
source of energy, you
will need these people.
AUDIENCE: So you need all
11 to work this boat.
If you put more, it's going
to be an overkill.
If you put less, it's basically
going to be--
so it's an optimized solution?
JOSEPH OZANNE: Exactly.
Because if you put less, you
could have less people to be
able to trim the
boat, so you're
probably going to be slower.
If you put more, you add
weight, which is--
you try to be as light
as possible.
So yes, at the end, it's
a good compromise.
But again, it's still
a sailboat.
So you need to only use human
power and the wind just to go.
AUDIENCE: Hi.
Is there an optimal amount
for the book to heel?
I noticed in the video that
sometimes, the upwind
hydrofoil is in the water,
but not always.
Do you want it in there for
the control surface?
Or out for less drag?
Can you talk about those
kinds of issues.
JOSEPH OZANNE: Yeah.
So what's happening
is so the boat--
as I was mentioning earlier--
it's a very complex machine.
So you need to find the proper
balance between what's
happening above the
water and what's
happening below the water.
And obviously when you go
against the wind, when you go
upwind, it's intuitively you go
maybe slower because you're
going against the wind.
And so the speed you are
reaching are slower.
I mean, even if upwind, we still
go 20, 25 knots upwind,
so against the wind.
And so overall, you go slower.
So you're going to need
to generate--
I mean, it's harder to generate
the lift to lift the
boat above the water.
So, you've got a trade off
between the amount of--
I mean, when you create
a force, it's
going to create drag.
So if you need to create the
seven tons on the foil upwind,
it's possible, but it can
obviously create some drag.
And then, you're going
to lift your hull.
And you are going to reduce
the drag of the hull.
So it's a trade-off between
how much you reduce the
hydrodrag and how much drag you
add by creating this force
on the foil.
So roughly, I mean, right now
with these boats, when you go
upwind you still have
the leeward
hull is still immersed.
And when you go downwind, we're
able to fly with winds
of 10 knots.
We can already be foiling.
So it's--
yeah.
It's all a matter
of compromises.
It's a trade-off between the
upwind and downwind and the
conditions.
AUDIENCE: I have
two questions.
One, the Bay is notorious for
its conditions in terms of
wind changes and so forth.
So I'm just wondering how much
that went into your design.
And then a complete different
question, you
talked about racing.
Over time, stuff developed in
racing cars has come down to
ordinary independent
suspension,
various things like this.
When can I expect a winged sail
on my 35 foot keel boat?
JOSEPH OZANNE: I will be very
happy to put one on your boat
if you want.
I mean, honestly, especially for
the sailing community, I
think it's much simpler
to handle.
So it's easier to sail, easier
to understand, you can
maneuver your boat with
more efficiency.
So obviously, logistically
it's a bit complex.
So if you can solve the
logistical issue, I'm pretty
sure that it can.
We see more and more
rigid wings.
And the good thing about the
America's Cup it's good
publicity for these wings.
And probably in the future
you can see that.
And I will even be happy to put
wings on a cargo ship or
something like that
just to save gas.
So it's just like a
kind of solution
which is quite reliable.
And regarding your other
question about the conditions
in the bay, I mean, we spend
a lot of time studying the
condition, the current.
We have historical data about
the previous years.
And if somebody can tell me
what's going to be the weather
on the seventh of September.
I mean, I'll take
the information
straight away, you know.
Because we can obviously
tune our boats, So
it's a bit of an unknown.
But I would love to know
the weather in
September for the race.
AUDIENCE: So my question
is about to the
technological advances.
And obviously it's great to
see all of the engineering
going into in those boats.
But I feel like it makes it
harder for competitors to
catch up, and more expensive
as well.
In particular, we went from
twelve or so challengers to
three this year.
So what--
JOSEPH OZANNE: Maybe
you should answer
you know more the--
AUDIENCE: So what do you see
the future of the America's
Cup based on that?
JULIAN GUTHRIE: I think there
will be a scaling back of the
size of the boats.
That's what Russell Coutts
has said to me.
But I think that the going
from twelve contenders to
three largely was a result of
the economy at the time and
the mortgage crisis that spread
abroad and really
caused global problems,
especially in Europe.
And caused a number of the teams
that were in Europe to
pull out of the race.
So I think the objective from
what I've heard from key
players, including Larry
Ellison, is to make this more
accessible.
I mean, it's never been
a race that has been
accessible to all.
The history of the America's Cup
is that you really need a
fat wallet.
And so I don't think that's
going to change.
But I think the boats will be
scaled down a bit in size.
That's what I've been told.
Interestingly enough, so Russell
Coutts said to me that
they had the AC45s, which
they used for the
World Series regattas.
But they needed a boat that
would look big enough, and
imposing enough, and enough like
an America's Cup boat on
television.
Where you would see it and say,
this is definitely an
America's Cup boat.
And so they went to the 72s.
But they found out, in
retrospect, that the AC45s
were also really
fantastic-looking for the mass
media market.
So I think that there will be
a bit of a scaling down.
What have you heard
about that?
JOSEPH OZANNE: Also, obviously
we've got less competitors,
but what we need to keep in
mind, is the level of
competition is very high.
So I mean it's still America's
Cup, and it's not easy to win.
So we need to keep
that because it's
still a tough challenge.
And right now, even if we have
less teams, the level of
racing is incredibly high.
So it's going to be a
tough win, for sure.
So this is one of the goals
of the America's Cup.
And it's for sure, this is
going to be the case.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: Jimmy Spithill
told me that in the past
America's Cup you've had a
dozen contenders but only
three or four really
viable competitors.
And so now, you don't have that
dozen, but you have the
really tough, viable competitors
that's that you're
going up against.
JOSEPH OZANNE: I mean, I've
been involved with the
campaign with Oracle in 2007.
And we had this group of-- we
called it the Big Four.
So even if you have 12
competitors, we still have the
Big Four which is really
the tough competitors.
So you knew before that these
guys would be in the
semi-finals.
So again, maybe we went straight
to the Big Four.
But it's just like, obviously,
there's some background that
Julian described.
So.
AUDIENCE: So I have a comment
and a couple questions.
And the comment is, do you think
that the-- or I guess
it's a question-- do you think
that the viable competitors,
is it a sport competition-type
competitiveness, or is it a
financial competition?
JULIAN GUTHRIE: It's
so multifaceted.
So you have to have the
engineering, and
the designing side.
And then you have to have
the material part of it.
The builders who know where
to get the best
grade of carbon fiber.
So it's all of those components
that you absolutely
have to have, which makes
it so complex.
And also so intellectually
stimulating for those involved.
JOSEPH OZANNE: I mean having
all that money around the
America's Cup it helps to
develop this kind of
technology.
And we're going to see this
technology in the future on
these kind of-- so it's help
improving the sport as well.
So it's expensive, but in
comparison with the sport,
it's not that expensive.
AUDIENCE: How do you keep the
boat from flying completely
out of the water and
losing control?
JOSEPH OZANNE: We need to find
a subtle balance between--
a boat is basically an
unstable machine.
So it can capsize, it can.
So we need to bring
some stability.
And so we can, by playing with
the shape of the foils, we can
bring some stability.
So when the boat is
flying, you can
maintain a stable flight.
But this kind of foils
or this kind of
shapes often is draggy.
So it just kind of create
too much drag.
So OK, it's flying, but
it's not that fast.
So we need to find where to
put the cursor between the
performance, the speed,
and the stability.
So the sailors should be
comfortable at flying the boat
and still be fast.
So it's part of our research
and development
to find this balance.
And so overall, we ended up with
a situation where we've
got a pretty unstable machine.
And we've got some input from
the crew to maintain a flight.
So for example, in our case, so
we've got this horizontal
wing, hydrofoil.
So it's a horizontal surface
that is immersed.
And we can change the
angle of attack
depending on the altitude.
So basically the crew is playing
with this angle.
So we can manually adjust the
flight from the crew.
And so we need to find the
correct balance between
stability and performance.
And it is part of our
day to day job.
AUDIENCE: Final question.
Can I get a ride?
JOSEPH OZANNE: Uh,
it's not my call.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: It's fun.
It's fun.
It's something else.
I was on one of the AC45s
and had quite a ride.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: I'm jealous.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: Yeah.
It's great.
JOSEPH OZANNE: You can come
and see the races.
They're going to be
races tomorrow.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: Yeah
the racing--
JOSEPH OZANNE: Two race.
JULIAN GUTHRIE: Two-boat
racing starts tomorrow.
So check it out.
AUDIENCE: You mentioned earlier
that when you went to
the fixed wing that there was
sort of a negotiation period
with sailors because they're
not used to flying that.
So what were the most
significant ways in which you
had to overcome a sailor's
natural inclinations?
Basically, what are the
significant differences
between flying a standard
sail and a fixed-wing.
JOSEPH OZANNE: It's still
a sailboat, so
it's doing the same.
So you try to propel
your boat.
So it's just doing the same
thing, except the tool you're
using to create the thrust
is different.
So we just need to make sure
that the sailors understand
that they still try to
create some thrust.
And it's still like a normal
sail plan, except that the
tool you're using
is different.
So the way you create this
force is different.
So the only thing is to teach
them what are the settings
that will be OK to recreate
what was happening before.
And then, so initially, it was a
bit complex for them because
you rely more on numbers and
data and everything.
Where, I mean, I remember during
the 2010 campaign where
we had this one of the quote
that you're going to find in
the book is normally a sailor
looks at his sail and checks
how it fly, how it's
in the air.
And when you go in an aircraft,
the pilot doesn't
look at his wing.
So it's just like, I just need
to get used to that.
But overall, at the end, the
sailor will still use his
feeling and how the
boat is loaded and
how the boat reacts.
So now they are the level where
they can use it properly.
[MUSIC PLAYING]